good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
5758 object class
ker special containment procedures
following the events detailed in SCP
5758 addendum no attempt is to be made
to interfere with SCP 5758 or the
movement of SCP 57
581 due to its small size and relatively
low refractive index no images of SCP 57
581 have been produced to date should
images of SCP 57 581 be produced in the
future they are to be immediately
discredited or explained to be an
optical illusion as most
appropriate description SCP 5758 is the
collective designation for the phenomena
and entities surrounding the tabon tomb
TT 147 and the modern Cult of consu SCP
57 581 is a group of AA lardi a tropical
species of moth over the course of a
lunar month SCP 57 581 Journeys to and
from the Moon first traveling towards
the moon for 14 days waxing to Full Moon
and returning to tabon tomb tt1 147
during the following 14-day period on
the night of the new moon members of The
Cult of consu will visit tomb tt1 147
one male and one female cultist will
enter the tomb and make their way to the
rear chamber once there they will
perform an extensive ritual ultimately
culminating in
coidus SCP
5758 extract from ritual text extract
from ritual text recovered from The Cult
of consu titled the night of power at
source the text is shown in both demoic
script and as an English
translation on the night of power does a
moon kneel before his bride here where
the Journey Begins and ends on the night
of power does a moon lie at top his
bride and place within her the
Traveler's
seed oh
kzu witness here your own
creation the joining of us to within
this tomb of plenty oh kanu witness here
our
Embrace beneath the shroud of your
rebirthing SCP 5758 2 is the male
offspring resulting from the successful
completion of this ritual based on
records kept by The Cult of consu there
are 642 living instances of SCP 5758 2 a
further 82 individuals born as a result
of the ritual are still alive but no
longer meet the criteria required to
complete the ritual cycle all SCP 5758 2
instances are raised within the cult
until mid adolescence at which time they
are strongly encouraged to leave Egypt
despite this all have maintained
relationships with their parents and
other cult members when the combined
mass of SCP 57 581 drops below the lower
threshold estimated at approximately 1
million instances the oldest eligible
instance of SCP 5758 2 will develop a
craving for the vegetation from rinus
communis Russ coriaria and fruit from
the citrus family approximately 3 to 6
months later the affected instance will
return to thieves where it will be
welcomed back into the cult on the night
of the next full moon the SCP 5758 2
instance will be taken to tomb TT 147
where its parents will wrap it in linen
and place it in the outer chamber then
on the night before the next new moon
the linen outer wrappings will split
releasing several hundred new SCP 57 581
instances newly emerged SCP 57 581
instances are identical to existing SCP
57 581 and are immediately assimilated
into the
group Discovery SCP 58 571 was first
observed in 1922 by Foundation
operatives working on nearby
archaeological excavations given the
apparent low-risk nature of the anomaly
minimal containment strategy were put in
place whilst based on anecdotal evidence
The Cult of consu was noted as a
potential group of Interest operatives
were unable to locate any modern cult
members and the group was recorded to be
defunct on 2018 2000 Kelly wad contacted
aan and Somerset police to report her
long-term partner Michael KH designated
SCP 5758 2A as missing watt claimed that
SCP 5758 2A had been acting unusually
for a 2-month period prior to
disappearance SCP 5758 2A had previously
mentioned that his family were members
of a religious group known as The Cult
of consu and the inclusion of this
detail in statements resulted in the
case being flagged for foundation
attention given that the cult of consu
had no reason to anticipate any
investigation mobile task force Theta 14
were quickly able to confirm SCP 5758
2a's travel route various belongings
including a phone passport and diary
were recovered from a property belonging
to SCP 5758 2a's parents similar
materials belonging to an additional 84
missing persons and archives documenting
the activities of the cult were also
retrieved from properties associated
with cult
members SCP 5758 extra s from Diary SCP
1A note SCP 5758 2a's diary was
recovered from a property belonging to
George and Alia
con 507
2003 it was the most delicious thing I'd
ever tasted just simple trout in lemon
butter but I couldn't get enough of it I
went back for more the next day and the
next even asked for the recipe
sumac in the
source I think I knew you then but I
wasn't ready to accept it I guess no one
ever really is it wasn't that I didn't
remember who could forget but I was 35
years old surely there must be some flaw
or imperfection to disqualify me by now
every day since 30 I was more and more
sure I wouldn't be
called time leaves no man
untouched but time is something I've run
out of this time at
least I quit my job a week later phoned
my parents to let them know your son is
coming home my bag is almost packed I'm
settling my Affairs and
she I told her it was me not her we both
cried but not for the same
reasons
2003 I've been saying goodbye to all my
favorite places finishing all the books
I never found the time to read had
coffee in that little shop I took her to
the first time added
lemon without it everything is bitter or
is the bitterness just me I have to go
last night I dreamed I stayed here that
they found me in my bathtub is some
melted misshapen thing
half formed into a god half I don't know
what I am and what I could have been was
taken from me before I was even born
what would I have chosen if but what
could be better than being a
god 267
2003 I'm not going I don't believe and
even if I do so what I don't want to be
a God I want my life my real life here
with Kelly II paid for the tickets and I
threw them away as soon as they arrived
the orang is with them screw it all I
didn't ask for any of this this morning
when I woke up there was Citrus on my
pillar 10:8 to
2003 I slept through the flight these
days I get so tired all I want to do is
eat and sleep
except I don't want
this I want to run and
hide except it it draws me back he draws
me back I guess and if I don't go who
knows what happens then in my dreams I
just lie down where I am and break apart
no rappings there to hold me in while I
become what come home to us become a god
consu The Traveler consu the
embracer I once watched a moth beat
itself to death against the window it
was so desperate to make it to the light
it had to know it couldn't get there
konu whose life is our hearts but mine
belongs belonged to someone else this
morning I switched off my phone I never
wanted to hurt her like this I couldn't
bear to see her calling
11:08
2003 they welcomed me back with so much
joy congratulations a feast fresh limes
and bitter oranges as many as I could
eat not for me though for the
god tomorrow my parents will I never
asked for any of
this I never
wanted
following the recovery of partial
remains with DNA matching SCP 5758 2A
and five other SCP 5758 2 instances tomb
TT 147 was sealed and members of The
Cult of kanu were detained for further
questioning SCP
5758 addendum following the ceiling of
Tomb tt1 147 SCP 57 581 was repeatedly
observed attempting to gain entry during
the new moon a significant number of
deceased SCP 57 581 instances were
collected outside of the Tomb and
preserved for
analysis on
130323 the total estimated number of SCP
57 581 dropped below 200,000 instances
over the next 6
months2 instances of SCP 5758 2 were
detained by Foundation person personnel
as they arrived in thieves with the
number increasing exponentially each
month from 2311 2003 markets and stores
within a 30m radius of the thean
necropolis experienced a 6000% increase
in citrus fruit sales additionally male
Foundation Personnel working in the area
reported severe food cravings and a
growing desire to visit the tomb on
81223 members of The Cult of konu were
permitted to prepare an instance of SCP
5758 2 under Foundation
supervision Personnel reported an
immediate cessation of cravings and
local citrus fruit sales gradually
returned to
normal SCP
5758 extract from ritual text 2 extract
from ritual text recovered from The Cult
of kzu titled the night of
transformation as previously the
original text is shown in both demotic
script and as an English
translation along with ritual texts and
incantations the volume includes
detailed instructions regarding how to
properly wash anoint and wrap SCP 5758
2 he has returned to you as you decreed
the span of his
years he has returned to this place that
we may wash and bind
him he will await you where the Journey
Begins his flesh reshaped to
Godliness he will await you until the
going forth of
men that you might then Embrace
him the soul of great consu may He
travel bravely through the night the
heart of the great
Gods may this child enrich the Lord
consul
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to
zargaran Big sip old crop guy James
sabba Irish
wwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazan worthy fire copster Dean
dangus that loser braded pitch Ruan
O'Brien
kegn Mr
duchak oscuro vision grimnir extra
moments 1
23 and Swift raw if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
you